This is amel's head of the Green Party.
And I have a few questions do you have 1 favorite saying in hessian?
Before I get upset about it,
I'd rather not care.
Which emoji best describes you?
What is the best thing about being party chairman?
Uh that's 1 primilegist uh a party that has given me
incredibly much um what I have and can come back.
How often do you actually talk to Monat Harald on the phone?
On average it is so drölf times a week and more often with
Anna Lena Annalena not more often because Annalena is much
more in time zones where many others sleep.
After all,
she is on the road for peace day and night.
Have you ever rapped?
Yes and do you still know one of your lines?
I know many of my lines but they don't belong here.
In search of unload,
you can see them around.
Ayyan Söder wants to live by,
but not in Bavaria.
Um you live 3 days ago too.
There is a song that definitely needs to be played with you.
I love to play.
Um at least the 1 8 bars of tschau.
Do you want to know who the babo is
and if you don't do that very strict people come and say
you have to get out of here now then we do that.
But it's good that you have people where you know they are
smarter better and they have everything under control.